[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROBERT KUBIS: Hello, everyone,
to the Cloud Spanner 101
session.
You might hear it already--
this session will be in English,
so I will not be
offended if you choose
another session if you don't
like me speaking in English.
I'm Robert Kubis.
I'm a developer advocate for
the Google Cloud platform.
So what does that mean?
We are basically the
bidirectional interface
between you guys who build
on top of the Cloud platform
and the developers that
build the Cloud platform.
So that's also why you see
there my Twitter handle.
Please reach out
with what you're
building on Cloud platform.
We like to feature things.
If you have
constructive feedback,
please reach out as well.
We try to improve the developer
experience further and further.
Now what am I going
to talk about today
is first, I'm going to basically
step back a couple of years
and give a brief history of
how we came up with Spanner
and why, and then explain
what Cloud Spanner is,
in particular.
I will show you
some demos and how
you can get started as well.
So what is Spanner?
Going back about 12
years-- like 2005--
and Google's business was on the
back of a sharded MySQL right?
So every dollar that we made
with advertising on our AdWords
system was backed by a
sharded MySQL system that
was sharded by a customer ID--
and then occasionally, we
had to reshard this system
to be able to grow even
further and further.
Now the last reshard that
we did took several years,
for a matter of fact.
And at that point,
we were saying, OK,
we can't do that any longer.
We-- like, our business
can't grow at the pace
that we are growing and
keeping all the qualities
with being on back of a sharded
traditional database system.
So that's why we
came up with Spanner.
We needed to build
a system which
has a lot of the qualities of
a traditional database system,
but has on top of this things
like horizontal scaling.
So we had a lot of customers.
We were growing very
quickly from a $10 million
business a year to a billion
dollar business a year,
and we were dealing
with people's money.
We had customers.
We had budgets that
they could set.
We had partners, agencies,
and things like that.
We couldn't work
with a system that
relies on eventual
consistency because this
would mean that we could lose
data and we could lose money.
Also, this system, Google,
is a 24/7, 365 business.
It's operating around the world,
and we cannot deal with any
kind of downtime.
Every time we are
down with our system--
with our backend systems--
it basically means
a lot of millions or thousands
of dollars that we are losing,
and our customers as well.
So prior to Spanner,
there was no such system
that where we basically could do
updates of our database system
with no downtime--
where we could
do schema changes
with no downtimes,
and things like that.
Now how does that
relate to Cloud Spanner?
Let's step 10 years
later, roughly.
And what we do
with Cloud Spanner
is basically making
this internal system
that we build for--
which our business relies on.
We make this available
to all of you.
So that means you have the same
performance and scalability
and consistency that we have
with our internal Spanner.
It's the same team
that builds it,
plus the team that builds the
integration with our Cloud
things.
And it's the same team
that keeps the reliability
of this system--
the system that
we use internally
as well as the
system that you get
to use on the Cloud platform.
So what was really
important here
was that this is
one system which
goes into the direction
of a cloud native systems.
So it's a fully managed system.
You basically can do with click,
set up your Spanner instance.
And you can scale
it transparently.
And also, what was
really important
when we built the
system internally
is people understood the--
to work with a
MySQL or PostgreSQL
relational database system
which has ACID transaction.
And it's much harder to
deal with a system which
has only low-level consistency
or eventual consistency.
Writing apps on top of that--
especially financial apps--
is really hard because you
have to build, basically,
your transactional
layer on top of this.
So we needed a system which
has the traditional semantics
of a relational database system.
So Spanner comes with these
traditional semantics as well.
We also wanted to integrate
with existing tools
and things like that.
So you can basically undust
your SQL skills and work
with Spanner like with
the familiar SQL language.
Now a really important
thing for us as well is--
I mentioned no downtime
and 24/7 business.
We really needed a
really reliable system.
We needed a system where we
can have high availability.
So if any hardware
failure is there,
that the database
doesn't go down.
And that we do by having
a synchronous replication
off the data in
Spanner and having
high reliability with this.
And I go in a little bit more
detail what that actually
means.
And what you also get with
putting your applications
on Cloud Spanner
is a system which
has been battle
tested within Google.
Our AdWords system relies
from the start on it.
But also, nowadays, a lot more
of the internal and external
apps that we have rely,
actually, on top of Spanner.
So for matter of fact, if you
look at Google Cloud platform,
the control plane, which
basically tracks everything
when you started GCE
instances and things
like that-- the control plane is
based on top of Cloud Spanner.
Now what Google is
really committed to
is being the open cloud.
So we try really hard to have
as least log in as possible.
So we try to integrate
open standards,
build a multitude
of client libraries
so that you can integrate
with your applications
that you already have existing.
So we have client libraries
and job [INAUDIBLE],,
and there are more
languages coming up.
We also have the GoPC
stop as open source
so you can build your own
languages-- own client
stops as well [INAUDIBLE].
We also provide currently
read-only gdpc driver
to integrate with tools like
business intelligence tools
and things like that.
What was really important
for us, as well,
for a cloud-based solution
is, from the start,
to integrate Cloud
Spanner with things
like audit locking,
identity and access
management, and encryption
on rest of your data.
Also, if you look
at the SQL language
standards that is used
within Google Cloud Platform,
it wasn't always that we
had a coherent story there.
So we put, actually, a lot of
effort in in the recent months
and years to standardize
on the SQL dialect
that we are using
throughout our products.
And Cloud Spanner
uses, also, SQL NZ 2011
as, for instance, Big Query
is using, with some extensions
on top of this.
Now we get asked a lot,
like, how does Cloud Spanner
compare to a traditional
relational database
system, or a
non-relational database
system-- like a so-called
NoSQL the database?
Now, if you compare
Cloud Spanner
to a traditional
relational database system,
you basically look at schema,
SQL, and consistencies.
And both of these
systems are like
a traditional
relational database,
and Spanner provide this.
Where they divert
is availability.
Now you can build a
high-available system
with a traditional
database system.
But usually, what that means
is you create a read replica.
You create a failover.
You have to manage all these.
And basically, with
a read replica,
you free up your master node a
little bit of the read workload
to get more performance
towards the right workload.
But your traditional
relational database
is only vertical
scaling database.
Now what it also means,
if you have a failover
instance or a read replica
in a sharded system,
you need to manage all these.
You need to manage
updates of the systems.
You might have to failover
your master to your failover
instance when you want
to take down your master
and update the hardware or
update the US, which basically
means even if it is planned,
you incur a downtime.
But this is not the
case with Spanner.
We don't have
downtime with Spanner.
The other thing is if you look
at scalability, as mentioned,
in a traditional
database system,
you basically have
vertical scalability, too--
and you can, to some extent,
go higher and higher instance,
like if you wait til your cloud
provider provides a bigger
machine.
And you hope that they provide
a bigger machine while you're
reaching the ceiling.
And you can do things
like read replicas
to free your master
from this read workload,
but you still have a ceiling
in terms of scalability.
If you compare Cloud Spanner
to a non-relational database
system, you already
see in the beginning
most of the NoSQL systems
don't have a rigid schema.
They don't have
necessarily SQL support
It might come with an
addition or some of them
partly provide an
SQL, but it's not
like you are used to it from
a MySQL PostgreSQL system.
And what's really important
is the consistency.
Now you have in certain
NoSQL database systems
the possibility to basically
tweak your consistency model.
But it comes with trade-offs.
It comes with trade-offs of
scalability and performance
of your system.
Now you don't need to make these
trade-offs with Cloud Spanner.
It's really performance out
of the box for read and write.
So what are the
typical workloads
that we see with Spanner
that we have seen in our EAP?
And now since Spanner
is beta and GA--
currently is actually
[INAUDIBLE] GA--
we've seen a multitude
of applications
that are moving to Spanner.
And I want to take out three
that are really important,
and which I think
where the Spanner has
really the strengths.
So I mentioned of scalability.
Now if you look at a system
in terms of scalability,
for your write and
your read scalability,
that's where Spanner
is really strong.
You can horizontal scale.
And you basically scale your
write and read very seamlessly.
So that's one thing
where you don't
have these limits that you
have on a traditional system.
Another really important
thing is with Spanner,
even though it's a
horizontal scalable system,
you have transactional.
You have asset, and you
have strong consistency.
Actually, we're really adamant
about this in the sense
that we have external
serializability
as our consistency
model in Spanner.
Now especially if you look at
a financial fin tag or things
like that, this is
really important
that you have these capabilities
and that transactions can
span rows and multiple tables.
You're not limited to a
certain part of your database.
What is also a really
strong use case for Spanner
is a global data plane where
basically Spanner comes in
as a highly available system.
Spanner is by design a
highly available system.
If you get a regional
set up, it comes up
with four nines of availability,
which is like four minutes
38 seconds of downtime a month.
Now if you use a
multi-regional set-up, which
comes later this
year, you go down
to 26 seconds of
downtime a month,
which translates to five
nines of availability SLA.
Now how does Spanner
actually achieve that?
How does Spanner
look under the hood?
So if you look at Spanner,
if you buy one node from us,
you basically get a node
which is replicated in three
zones in a regional instance.
So you have your
regional instance,
and you have your
replication of your compute
and your storage in three zones.
Now what's really important
here is that storage and compute
are separated in a
way that they are
independent from each other.
So you can scale
compute and storage
independent from each other.
So what does it mean?
What are all these terms?
If you look at Spanner,
you start with an instance.
That's something
that you basically,
when you create your
Spanner database,
you start with an
instance where you
define which region do I want
to have my Spanner instance in?
And how many nodes do I want to
have for my Spanner instance?
Now in the Spanner instance, you
can create up to 100 databases.
And in this database you
can create a multitude--
up to 200--
hundreds of tables.
Now these are the
concepts that are
used to form a traditional
database system.
And these are the concepts
that are visible to you.
Now behind the
scenes, we actually
split these tables
in so-called splits,
or in contiguous key ranges.
So based on your primary key, we
basically choose contiguous key
ranges and split your table.
That enables us to do the
horizontal scalability
for write and read.
So if you look,
you basically have
your splits that are replicated
three times in each zone.
You have your nodes.
And for this example right
now, we look at only one node.
So you buy one node from us.
This is replicated
in three zones.
Now what is really important is
that to be strong consistent,
you really have to make sure
that only one is writing
basically to a certain
split, and it's
in control of that data piece.
Now what we use in Spanner is
the so-called Paxos algorithm,
which is a majority voting
to vote leader in that group.
So we have basically Paxos
groups spans all three zones.
And they are basically
based on the split.
So you have for
each replica, you
choose one leader
in your Paxos group.
Now if you know and you come
from a distributative role,
you know making sure that
you actually have only one
leader at any point
in time, it requires
a lot of communication.
Now communication is expensive.
And that would basically
mean that you slow down
your database.
So what Google did is
they invented actually
a system which removes
the need of a lot
of these communication.
And that system is
called TrueTime.
So what is TrueTime?
So if you compare your
watches with your neighbor,
and you go out and you
come back in five minutes,
if you have really detailed
watches in milliseconds,
your watches will have
drifted from each other.
The reason is atmospheric rays.
It is temperature.
It's pressure, all
kinds of things
that interfere with how fast
your clocks are running.
So keeping clocks in sync across
oceans and across data centers
is a really, really,
really hard problem.
Now what Google
did is they build
a system based on or consisting
of atomic clocks and GPS
synchronization to synchronize
the clocks in all data centers.
Now it's not a wall
clock time that you
get actually one timestamp.
What is really smart here
is actually you get a range.
You get kind of like
a range of time.
And what is this range?
So you get a lower bound and
an upper bound timestamp.
The lower bound timestamp means
that this time has definitely
passed everywhere in the world.
The upper bound timestamp
means that this timestamp
has definitely not passed
everywhere in the world.
And by the technology
that we have used,
we can basically get
this interval down
into a couple of milliseconds.
And by having this
global wall clock time,
we can make sure that we have
exactly one leader for a split
at any point in time.
And by that, we can
make sure that we
have strong consistency
in the transactions
that we are running in Spanner.
Now let's show a
little bit how that
looks like when you look
actually at a query that
runs against Cloud Spanner.
So in this case, I want
to do a consistent read.
It basically means I
really want to have
the latest data at that point.
So what I start with is
my client sends a request.
And it goes into
a front end, which
figures out where
the responsible split
for this query is.
So there's a transparent
routing basically happening.
Now in this case, we are routed
to a slave, or a replica,
which is closest to us.
And that replica basically
says, OK, this is a strong read.
So I need to check if
I have the latest data.
So it will do a request to
the leader of that split.
And it will get back, yeah,
you have the latest data.
And then we basically can
serve that data from the slave,
from the read replica.
Now in the case that you have
actually not the latest data--
so we ask basically the leader,
do I have the latest data?
The leader will
respond back, no, you
don't have the latest data.
But just wait a couple
of milliseconds,
and you will have it.
So it's not that
with this request
we are sending
actually the data.
Most likely at the point
that we are asking the leader
if we have the
latest data, the data
is already in flight
to the replicas
so that we will basically
be in sync at a later point.
So what basically happens
is the slave will wait out
that time till it's up
to date to the timestamp
when the request came in.
And then once the
time is waited out,
we can respond with the data.
Now the thing is, there might be
use cases where you don't want
to stress your leaders basically
with these calls to check
if I have the latest data.
There might be use cases
where you can read stale data,
where you're OK to
read stale data.
And especially if you look
at a multi-regional set up
where you have
replication globally,
this might be a good thing
to actually answer really
quickly to your clients.
Now how can you do this?
The way to do this is
through so-called use
stale queries where you give
a time bound of how much
staleness you allow.
So in this case I
basically say, all right,
I want to have data which is
at maximum 15 seconds old.
Now this comes in again through
one of our read replicas.
And the read replica checks
basically timestamp of the data
that it has for this
data that is requested
and checks against the
timestamp bound and sees,
OK, I have data
which is definitely
newer than the timestamp bound.
So I can return and
respond directly
before without involving
the leader at all.
Now the next concept is
read-write transaction.
And just what I've
mentioned before,
if you saw it the read-only
transaction that I
talked in the beginning, it
didn't have any logs that way.
So read-only
transactions can actually
work without setting any
logs and slowing down
my read-write transactions.
Now in a read-write
transaction, what I basically
do is when the request comes
in through my front end that
does the routing, the
routing is directly
done to the leader
of my Paxos group.
Now the leader acquires
logs and sends back
the query results
for the read that I'm
doing in my transaction.
Now then I'm doing something.
I do a calculation.
I'm adding some money to
it or things like that.
And I'm sending back basically
the write that I want to do,
the update of the data.
Now in that case, we have
the logs already acquired.
What we do is we're sending
the write to our read replicas.
And as soon as a
majority comes back
from this read replica,
which includes myself,
the leader, at that point
I can basically say,
OK, the data is going
to be committed.
So I can respond
already to my client
and say, OK, I can respond
and release the logs.
And any replica that hasn't
responded up to that point
basically will catch up.
So I mentioned that
Spanner is based
on the semantics
that you are used
to from a relational
database system, be it MySQL,
be it PostgreSQL, or any of
the major database vendors.
Now you have very
familiar constructs.
You have tables with columns
which have the standard SQL
data types.
So it's strongly typed.
And what you can do
here, for instance,
you have a singers table
and a albums table where
you can define primary keys.
Now there is one thing.
You don't have foreign key
constraints in Spanner.
But you have a
different concept,
which is kind of like a foreign
key constraint minus minus,
which we call
interleaved tables.
Now what are interleave tables?
I was just talking about Spanner
being distributed system,
a horizontally
distributed system.
And any time you need
to do any communication
to get your data together to
do a response, that basically
means time more spent
for actually getting
your query results
to your clients.
So if you have
certain queries where
you want to co-locate the
data, where you basically you
want to do some kind
of a [INAUDIBLE],,
you can use the construct
of interleave tables, which
basically ensures the
co-location of that data.
And very straightforward
to do this.
You basically do the
singers table here,
and then the album
table undefined.
And the album table is
an interleaved table
of your singers table.
Now there are certain schema
things that you can do.
And there are certain things
that you should not do.
So like anti-patterns
that are used
to do in a vertical
scalable database system
are here actually hurting
if you move to Spanner.
So I want to point
out a couple of those.
One is I mention that
Spanner tables are split up
by contiguous key ranges.
Now you can imagine if you
use a monotonic in increasing
or decreasing primary
key, you basically
always end up in one
split if you basically
append to this table.
So you are hot spotting
on that one split,
and that restricts
your scalability.
Now basically the way
that we get write and read
scalability is by
moving around the splits
that I mentioned earlier
to different compute nodes.
So if we see one of the
compute nodes is very busy,
we basically take away that
split and give it another one.
And by that, we have
to scalability in reads
and writes.
Now if you use monotonic
increasing primary keys,
and that always goes
through the same split,
you're basically
hot-spotting on a part,
which we cannot
distribute any further.
So also don't use timestamp
for this, for instance.
Another thing is
where you also want
to be careful as
I just mentioned
the technique of interleaving.
But use it in a way that
you don't over-interleave,
because this also means--
data co-location
means you can also
hotspot on certain
things in your tables
if you overuse interleaving.
So here's an example of
what I just talked about.
So if you have for instance,
here a timestamp that we use,
and if we insert always with a
timestamp as our primary key,
it all goes to one split.
Now how can I avoid this?
So one good practice to
avoid this is using UUIDs.
So we recommend using UUIDs
version 4 as primary keys.
Now there might be certain
situations where you cannot do
this.
So what you also can do is you
can use a sharding key in front
of your timestamp, if you need
to use timestamp, for instance.
Or monotonically
increasing numbers,
you can basically use a
sharding key in front of it
to accommodate that.
Another thing what you want
to do if you move to Spanner
is really designing your schema
on your primary workloads,
so that your primary
workload performs best.
So here's an example
of how we basically
prefixed our primary
key with a sharding ID.
And by that, we can split up the
inserts into multiple splits,
and we can move
these splits around
to different compute nodes
to have the scalability.
Now we switch to
the demo computer.
To get started
with Cloud Spanner,
your first stop is
cloud.google.com/spanner.
And this gives you all the
information and high level
of what Spanner is, but also
all the pointers to client
libraries and things like that.
What I want to point out here
is on the bottom of this entry
page, you see things
like a comparison
of how does cap, for
instance, play into Spanner?
Does it defeat it or not?
Things like that.
So [INAUDIBLE] took
a take on explaining
Spanner and the [INAUDIBLE] and
how TrueTime plays into that.
Also what are really nice
and really great material
is, if you come from a sharded
MySQL or sharded PostgreSQL,
we have Cloud Spanner case
studies which explain to you
how you can do this transition
from such a system to Spanner,
and how you have to take
care of certain things.
So [INAUDIBLE],, one of
our early access partners,
basically customers did the
transition for a sharded MySQL
to Spanner, and they
explain in detail
what kind of considerations
they had to do.
Now for the
remainder of my demo,
I want to go back to the schema
that you saw earlier today
in the keynote.
So what we had
there is a scenario
of a ticket sales system.
And this ticket
sales system, it's
really important that we sell
each ticket exactly once.
So that's why we choose to
use Spanner for that use case.
Now we wanted to have it
is somewhat realistic.
So actually we came
up with some schema
to make it somewhat realistic.
So what you can see here is
it all revolves around events.
So you have multiple
events which
you can categorize
in a multi-event,
like a tour of a singer or
a star or things like that.
And then we have venues.
These venues have different
seating categories
like general admission, or
VIP, or premium and things
like that.
Now these the
seating categories,
we actually choose to
interleave directly in the menu
because we have to fetch
them very often together.
And then we have different
prices for our events.
So we actually do
connect ticket categories
to seating categories, and
then have all our tickets
in our database.
So in this database that we
showed in the keynote today,
we had up to 1 billion tickets
actually in the database
that you can sell.
Now while this
database is running,
I can actually do things
like running queries.
So in this case, I
have a query which
looks at the seats available
for events that are going on
right now till midnight today.
So you see down here
in my where clause, I'm
looking at what's happening
right now till midnight,
or actually 2 AM?
And I look for all the events
that are going on in Spain.
So now when I run this, I will
see that this will actually
take a while.
And I might look at it and
say, OK, this is not actually
for a transactional system where
I need to do this check really
quickly, eight seconds is
definitely too long to do this.
Now what you can do with
Spanner is actually directly
in our cloud console, you
can inspect your queries.
And you can check what
is the career plan?
What you're basically used to
from any other major database
where you can actually
see what is the database
doing behind the scenes?
And as we can see
here, we are actually
scanning a lot of rows.
And scanning a lot of
rows is pretty expensive.
So what you can do as
in the major database
systems is to actually give the
optimizer, degree optimizer,
some hints on what to do.
So in this case, I have an
index defined on my event table
which will help me
to boil down the data
that I'm actually reading.
So in this case, that's one
of the extensions where I say,
OK, I want to force the
index use event by day.
And you see right
now it's coming back
in much faster in 1.4 seconds.
And if we look at
the explanation,
you'll see that the rows
scanned boils down a lot.
So you have the
possibility to also tweak
your queries in that way.
Now I have a play database.
And I want to show you
really quickly how you
can get started for
instance, with Java
and running your own queries
with Java and Spanner.
So if you set up your
environment, the first thing
that you need, you need
to basically authenticate
against Spanner.
And if you have G Cloud
installed on your machine,
or if you run your
workload on GCE,
you have something called
application default
credentials.
And so you see here, I just
go to googlecredentials.get
application default
and basically it
uses my contacts that I'm
running this application in
and does all the
authentication for me.
So that's pretty quick.
The next thing that
I want to do is
I need to define which
instance do I want to talk to?
And which database
do I want to talk to?
So very standard,
the [INAUDIBLE]
is taken from the application
default credentials,
so I don't have to
define that here.
So I only define the instance
name and the database name.
The next thing that I
need is I basically need
to start up my database client.
So in this case, I
would just basically
get my database with
all the information
that I just mentioned,
like project ID, instance
ID, and database ID.
And then I can basically
start running transactions.
So the first thing
that I'm going to do
is I going to show you
a read-only transaction.
So in this case, I basically
get from my database client,
and say, OK, I just want to
do one run off of a query.
So I get a single use
read-only transaction.
So this doesn't keep
this transaction open.
It basically gives
you the possibility
to run one query,
get the results back.
And that transaction is over.
We are using in this
case, a read-only action
because I don't want to acquire
any logs on Spanner, as I
mentioned before.
Now we basically do our query.
In this case, I'm just
getting all events that
are happening right now till--
basically 10 events which
are open for sale right now.
And I need to, of course,
go through my result set.
So results, and,
like as you are used
to from iteratable
collections, you
basically you can just
iterate through your results
set, and print out the results.
So in this case, as you can
see in my select statement,
I select the multi-event
ID and the name.
So I just get string.
And you can choose
either the column name,
the column in your SQL query.
Or you can choose
actually the column index.
So in my case, I'm
choosing the column index,
and then I'm running it,
and, fingers crossed,
if I'm successful, it it will
come back and basically-- oh.
Why is this?
That was not--
All right.
Demo fail.
[INAUDIBLE] Of course.
All right.
So here, in this case, basically
I'm executing the read.
I'm getting my
multi-event IDs back.
And I get my [INAUDIBLE].
So, nice.
The next thing that
I want to do is
I want to do a
read-write section.
Now we have the exact same
thing that I just showed--
so I'm not going to
type all this again--
up to the point that we
basically get the client.
And then you see something
here called mutations.
So what are mutations?
The construct in
Spanner is everything
which basically changes
data is called a mutation.
We have a couple of
restrictions on mutations.
So one thing is
your transactions
shouldn't be bigger
than 10 megabytes.
So the sweet part is about
one megabyte per transaction.
Another thing is you shouldn't
change more than 20,000 cells
in your transaction.
What does that mean, a cell?
Now we have a
table for instance,
with five columns,
five attributes.
Now, if you change a table, if
you have no indexes defined,
and you insert a row in
this table of five columns,
you end up with five mutations.
Now, if you have an index
defined on your table, which
basically indices two
columns of your table,
then you have another
two mutations.
So if you insert a row, and you
have a table with five columns,
and an index with which
index two columns,
you end up with seven mutations.
Now the limitation is to not
have more than 20,000 mutations
within one transaction.
Now what I'm doing here is
basically I'm getting a UUID.
I'm setting a name, country
code, email address,
and adding--
in this case, I'm not
having any tickets,
so I'm adding null there.
And I'm just running this.
And that basically
inserts an account for me.
So as you can see here,
if I go in preview,
I have in this case, three
accounts added to my database.
Now if I wanted to
an update-- this
was a write-only transaction.
Now if I want to do
an update, I basically
do a read-write transaction.
And in this case, what
I am starting with,
what I'm getting is I'm using
a so-called transaction runner.
And this transaction
runner, which
you give it a basically
a runnable, where
you abstract array.
You give it a basic
function to execute.
Why are we doing this?
The reason for this is you
basically give the client
a function to execute.
And if the client will
by itself do the redo
if the transaction fails.
So you basically give
that to our client.
And you don't have to care
about redo and rerunning
your transactions in
case that they fail.
In this case, I'm basically
reading all the accounts
with my email address,
and I'm updating my name
on these accounts.
So once this is run,
as you can see here,
I can go back to
my preview, and you
will see that the name has
changed in all three rows.
Now last but not least,
what I want to show
is I want to clean up
as well, of course.
And the way that you can select
data with the client library
is not only per SQL.
You can also use the read APIs.
And for instance,
here, in this case,
I want to delete
all the data that I
have in my account table.
So I use the keyset
all, where I should not
use an SQL statement.
I actually use a
mutation where I
say I want to have just
everything in this table,
based on the keyset all,
and just delete this.
And once we do
this, you will see--
so basically you can
choose between SQL
and our read APIs to
work with Spanner.
And so we go back
and we go here,
we will see that all
the data is being gone.
All right.
Going back to the slides,
so how does Spanner
compare to all
the other products
that you might have
heard about today
or you might hear in the
future or did you hear about
in the past?
So there's a multitude
of different kinds
of storage and database
products under GCP.
So if you look at more
in-memory database,
and you're writing your
applications in App Engine,
you can use App Engine
Memcache, for instance.
Now, if you have
something where you
don't need the
high availability,
the horizontal
scalability for write
and read, and the
database which can
grow across terabytes of data.
So our example demo
database that we
had had 30 terabytes of data.
If you look at it like a
traditional vertical scalable
database system,
you basically end up
with a couple of terabytes
that you can scale to,
and then it gets
really difficult.
So if you don't
have a lot of data,
if you don't need a
high available system,
and if you want to run
applications that are already
well integrated with things
like MySQL or PostgreSQL,
then you can use our managed
Cloud SQL service, which
provides you MySQL or PostgreSQL
as a managed solution,
with the possibility to do
read replicas and failovers,
and things like that.
Now if you need the things
that I just mentioned--
horizontal scalability,
high availability,
things like that--
then you want to
start with Spanner.
Now if you don't need the
relational data model,
if you want a more
NoSQL data model,
and you don't need the
transactional consistency
and [INAUDIBLE] semantics
that Spanner and Cloud SQL
flavors are providing, then
we have Cloud Datastore
for a more document
based hierarchical model.
Or if you look at a system where
you have basically key value
base, then you have
Cloud Bigtable,
which provides you tremendous
write and read performance
in single digit milliseconds
for really high throughput.
Cloud Datastore
and Cloud BigTable
are fully managed solutions
as well, which are innovated.
You don't think about
machines anymore.
They scale with your
needs from start
to terabytes and
petabytes of data.
Now if you have
non-structured data,
you're looking at cloud
storage for instance.
And if you are looking into
a data warehouse system
where you'd want to do analytics
with a more full fledged SQL
support, then you look into
BigQuery, for instance.
Now there are a
couple of decisions
that you can make along the way,
if you are at the point where
which systems should I use?
It's basically a reiterations of
the slide that we saw earlier,
where you basically
can ask yourself
a couple of questions in terms
of, is your data structured?
If not, you can go
to cloud storage.
If you need a mobile SDK,
you can go to Firebase
and use Firebase Storage to have
all the integrations with IoS
as Android and a
lot of the SDKs.
Now if your data is
actually structured
and you want to do
analytics on top of it,
then you're looking
more to the things
like Cloud BigTable
and BigQuery.
If your primary workload
it is non-analytical,
then you make the decision
between relational
versus non-relational, where
in the relational case,
you go to Cloud SQL or Spanner,
and the non-relational case
you go to Cloud
Datastore or Firebase DB.
And with that, I'm
done with my talk.
And thank you so much
for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]